for a 30 second spot in Sunday's Super
Bowl that's up from 5.6 million in 2021
and six and a half million last year but
our next guest says seven million
dollars is actually underpriced joining
us now from Arizona vaynermedia CEO Gary
vaynerchuk uh and he has well
vaynermedia has three spots coming in
this year's big game Gary uh great to
have you on uh initially just just tell
me why seven million dollars is is a
bargain for uh for an Advertiser this
year I mean it all comes down to
attention right like the reality is his
attention is the number one asset and
not potential attention and you have the
entire country actually focused on
watching Super Bowl ads which is unlike
any other television commercial that
runs in any shape or any form obviously
the commercial has to be good to make
the thing happen but the attention is
underpriced compared to the cost per
attention in every other environment
that we see in Digital television or
traditional advertising is this just
because I mean if a hundred million
people in the U.S watch it that's some
of the estimates this year if that's the
case that yeah it's always been the most
widely watched event of the year but
compared to the single audience of any
other program show any place you can
find people assembled it's that much
bigger on a relative basis does that
actually translate directly into return
on investment no it doesn't it's that
Americans actually want to watch the
commercials nobody wants to watch the
commercials on the Grammys nobody wants
to watch the commercials on the Oscars
nobody wants to watch the commercials in
the AFC and NFC Championship game or the
NBA finals this is the only time people
in America actually want to watch a
commercial thus rendering it the best
deal while all the other commercials on
television are grossly overpriced
how do you if you're talking to your
clients you have as I said some ads uh
in this Super Bowl coming up Pepsi Zero
sugar for example how are they going to
determine whether they got a good return
on their investment
sales you know amortized over time it's
not like the next day but you look at
sales in a window and you look at what
you're able to do with the leverage of
the awareness like right now you're
playing you know a Mr Peanut uh piece of
content that you have plenty of people
that watch the show I got previewed I
got like 30 texts right now you have a
real audience here and they're watching
Mr Peanut now and subconsciously that
may lead to them choosing a Planter's
product versus another product in the
next week or day or months but
ultimately this is about business this
isn't about making people laugh or being
too silly like it's great to have Steve
Martin in this but we want people to
really focus on considering to try Pepsi
Zero and so this is about business
yeah it's interesting in the sense that
the more the broader digital advertising
environment has to a large degree been
about targeting and you know point of
sale type things and and trying to be
very actionable
um and narrow casting in a way and so
this is kind of the opposite what are
you seeing in terms of your clients
right now if let's say you're being a
little more careful about overall ad
spending what are they prioritizing in
those other platforms
well it's interesting you just talked
about the difference between branding
and sales and to your point digital has
been very focused on conversion The Meta
Facebook world really mattered and
worked right now what everyone's focused
on is building brand in social people
are starting to realize that your brand
is built in Social much more than in
regular TV commercials non-super bowl or
in Billboards or in print that social
brand not selling people but putting out
content that makes them interested in
the product or consider the product is
exploding and so it will continue to
gain market share because social media
is where a shocking amount of human
attention is being allocated to but what
we finally are starting to see is The
Branding elements enter the social
sphere much more than just trying to
make it a sales conversion Channel
which platforms are best suited for that
uh in your view I mean Tick Tock
obviously now maybe the greatest number
of minutes spent but Instagram
traditionally is seen as being friendly
to that type of thing too
it's a great call out I would say it's
where your strategic creative lands
meaning Believe It or Not LinkedIn for
some consumer products is over
performing Twitter or Instagram for
certain brands because they understand
how to make the videos or pictures or
written words that hit that audience
better it is a massive Battleground for
the advertising agencies like
vaynermedia and the Fortune 500 Brands
to outflank their competitors in
Creative strategy we call it sock
strategic organic content are you
posting to just say happy Friday or are
you actually putting out content to
build brand and so any of the platforms
you just listed on the screen can
dominate for Brands is the punch line
are you good at Twitter are you good at
Instagram are you good at Tick Tock and
certain humans are better at certain
platforms but the biggest brands in the
world over the next decade will be built
on the people that can execute best on
all of the platforms so they're hitting
as many customers as possible cheers
thank you for having me take care
awesome
it was a really good hit yeah it was
great
[Music]